[Music]
ever a big fan inebriated this entire
does have you've been amazing this year
though it's been great for our back good
morning ladies and gentlemen let's find
out how the birthday girl feels this
morning
Oh still my birthday it's your birthday
as soon as the truce is over that's when
your birthday is over okay thank you
I guess I'll take it yeah good morning
today is a new day and we've all morning
with that attention the general
emergency alarm is about to be sounded
for exercise purposes over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they're tiny versus
morning you're ready for Mexico I am
ready for Mexico
yeah Raver that looks really weird I'm
making those sound effects scary to me
it helps me get a steady shot I thought
it was a bug my neighbor I was you your
face is special we are in Ensenada now
we're about to get off the boat are you
excited to be back in Mexico we were
just here like six months ago
yeah I mean I don't know this doesn't
really count as Mexico cuz it's like
super tourist versatile US territory
here Mexico
[Music]
[Applause]
you more sports are you wearing shorts
your life cat calls out the wazoo
unless that room
but let me know
and first a little
Oh
me
Oh
so right now we want to make global area
or following our tour guide he's taking
us to the blog but there's a lot of
shops smells like the BS this place is
really touristy it feels like we're
walking it's like we're walking through
is being part of Mexico Mexican the time
part house in Tanana has a mix bit
annoying actually a bit annoying how
come I don't like doing imparted like
this yeah here's another vendor oh no
thank you no thank you
this is a nice experience that we get to
have with everyone
the only people missing though is Joe
and Joe we don't know what happened of
it but other than that everyone else is
here we get together and look at Isaac
having a blast with Brian and Kyle
there's like so many pouring those green
tags
we're Jers hey because it is pocket we
like the way 200 the driver forced me to
he did yeah I was reading in my pocket
us all you should put that on your shirt
I was like sitting next to like I guess
oh let's go there fighting what is the
thing they eat here it's another
resource moistures choices a splendid
[Applause]
[Music]
are you good which one are you are you
more mixed in
like they're in the middle 5050
they look delicious to you Isaac do you
know what it is yeah
looks disgusting to you I split it right
down the middle smells good though
she needs slow motion well alright such
a slow motion real quick
[Music]
[Music]
pretty much
let's put some more legs it looks kind
of drug
but it is really fresh looking oysters
right and I'm assuming it right out
there somewhere over there and before I
you can test all the bosses in the line
tiers numbers needed by so wrong I want
to get the taste of how fresh it is
without covering it good Oh
[Music]
my order lambs just game so it's wrong
lamb dressed with some tomato and some
avocado and some sort of brown sauce
[Music]
cooked in lime drizzle and some photo
sauce usually they beat this dish we're
quite pleased you ever want to order it
I don't like my penis like like you
think allow them get this dish it's
really spicy - all right so we ordered a
spicy just because we're gonna be
walking around for the rest of the day
everybody feels like really
if you're gonna be out of commission for
a day
I just a really strong one for you don't
know tasted whooping are you idle amazed
in uterus today arm rested going on
right here
[Applause]
let me see thank you
[Music]
crazy baby we just met on this video
sorry I'm
you
all right so we finished our lunch
sorry if I'm slurring because they
forced me to take two shots I really
really really hate hard liquor so that
was really difficult for me to do but I
don't want to let people down
so it did it but anyways we're we have
like 20 minutes left
what we need is about little bus so
we're gonna try to enjoy this amazing
view it's beautiful oh you can see the
blowhole over there
cool we got like the best view you taste
the salty water over your mouth berry we
got like 12 minutes everyone down there
got soap here you how free is the exit
Oh hold on a sec are you crying are you
crying oh oh it's crying it's what
you've been working for your whole life
dude oh man this is amazing
whoo little sugar shoulders here oh yeah
dude oh you guys dude that that is I I'm
getting emotional right now recording
you first independent film unlike a 60
to 80 K budget 60 to 80 K budget about
an Asian American story and I got into
Sundance nobody ever wants to hear an
Asian American perspective and got this
understand this is one of the most
competitive
vessels you can never get into
especially on an art scale you know I
think like you're on YouTube for so much
and my thing is you can always tell
somebody that you don't like what they
do but you got to walk the walk to if
you're gonna talk to [ __ ] so for me this
film was that it feels good maybe I
don't know I don't know hopefully back
to the cruise says we're all right tired
it was fun it's another fun right it was
a very very touristy kind of way seafood
is really fresh and like everyone else
staying on the trip took a four-day
cruise just to gets us to 92 hours yep
good stuff alright we're back on the
boat and now we are ship is it a ship or
a boat I can't ever tell now the sunset
view of Ensenada
[Music]
you're that
now we're coming to an end
if we're going back to LA tomorrow how
is your trip in it's been incredible I'm
like speechless because it's been such a
dope amazing awesome cool experience hey
what about you so we are know these sea
lions are really distracting I know I
think it's pretty funny I mean they're
cheating or something
how's your experience been I've actually
liked this experience surprisingly
actually because I typically don't like
resorts typically don't like matching
out I like walking a lot I like figuring
things out trying being uncomfortable
and I vacationed because they know I
think that's what vacation is all about
theoretically it's you want to get out
of your bubble and if you get out your
bubble then that means you're getting
out of your comfort zone but this though
is more like you're leaving one bubble
and you're entering another bubble and
we're stuck on a boat like it's
literally a bubble and you're being
pampered you don't have to think for
yourself everything just kind of served
to you on a platter but with that though
it comes another kind of experience and
it comes a different kind of enjoyment
knowing that and kind of trying to
welcome that idea I think I've come to
really enjoy this trip too I think you
and Isaac has kind of made it very
pleasant for me there's a lot of
downtime there's a lot of just like
we're not doing anything but because I'm
with you too though it's like I feel the
family bonding and I think that's the
most important part yeah so I've accad
the chance to go to his like kid club
thing this whole time
but the only time he's ever been there
was when we went for the registration
like in on the first day where we all
got to hang out with him and we keep
asking him like do you want to go hang
out of your kids club make some friends
or go play some video games if you want
you know like it's there it's available
but he keeps saying like no I want to
spend with you guys I want to be with
you guys so that's really sweet to that
he wants to be with us he wants to be
with his parents that's number one I'll
always be number one no experience no
novelty will ever preside over family
time we're creating memories that you
know we're gonna hold with us forever
especially with Isaac cause right now
his childhood it's like it's molding him
into the person he's going to be so for
him to be able to travel the world and
have different experiences with
different cultures and it's really nice
to see him have fun and grow creating
memories we've actually been on this
super mega long vacation the sense that
is the holiday in his Christmas runo
throw this out there first before we go
back in time to visit Florida and the
rest of our Texas adventures baby it's
good